all right y'all we have time for one
more uplifting story this is what I'm
liking
[Music]
[Applause]
to find unique ways to connect with the
community but probably none are as
unique as this officer from Maryland
[Music]
so beautiful officer Alexander strong of
the Prince George's County Police
Department has been playing violin all
his life beautifully might I add he says
music is a bridge to the community I
could not agree more let's get him in
here everybody all right Officer stunt
how you doing
hi Kelly it's so nice to meet you nice
to meet you as well wow first of all you
have a beautiful smile my goodness
um well you you only race you're welcome
you only recently joined the police
force is that right yes I joined about
two years ago it's been such an honor to
be a officer for the princess County
Police I've had the opportunity to be
able to play violin in uniform so it's
so neat to be able to help be a bridge
for the community I get to go and that
was at the wellness house I get to play
different communities and Charities and
represent the police department they
will go in nursing homes and it's so
cool because people see the gun and
badge and think well what's going on
what's going on and they see me playing
the violin and the glass is so cool so
it's an amazing opportunity and such an
honor I'm incredibly blessed
light so how did you was it your
grandparents is that what started you in
the nursing homes
so my grandmother she had Alzheimer's
and breast cancer and music was
something that brought her back to me
despite the fog of the Alzheimer's and
it was that amazing connection that I
could have being able to play music for
her especially the day before she passed
away and I wanted to continue that work
in nursing homes and for people in
hospices while playing for terminally
ill children adults by the bedside
that is such a cool thing man you're so
rad can we hear a little bit of Amazing
Grace
absolutely it's one of my grandma's
favorites I love I love it mine too
[Music]
that's so good thank you so much thank
you officers
right now
that's not all the our season-long
partner pilot pit makers of friction the
go-to rightful pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show are inspired by your dedication to
your community and the memory of your
grandmother so they are going to write
you a check for a thousand dollars on
your behalf to the wellness house thank
you so much dedicated to serving
families who have been touched by cancer
thank you so much thank you have a
blessed day and thank you to everybody
all our guests are Hannah wanttingham
Reid Scott Garrett and Emily coffin you
have a great day if it's not time
changes foreign
[Music]
[Applause]